Off.
Survoler la Terre.
Ce doit être l’une des plus merveilleuses
expériences à vivre ! De là-haut, non seulement
la vue est imprenable, mais surtout, dans
la station spatiale internationale, on a la
chance d’expérimenter cette sensation unique
qu’est l’apesanteur.
Enfin, c’est ce qu’on m’a dit, je n’y
suis jamais allé moi-même…
Mais une seconde…
Est-ce que l’on est vraiment en apesanteur
là-haut ? Il y a une superbe vidéo de Veritasium
à ce sujet.
Off.
En fait, les astronautes ne sont que quelques
centaines de kilomètres au-dessus de la Terre.
Par opposition, la Lune est à des centaines
de milliers de kilomètres.
Comparé à la Lune, les astronautes sont
encore collés à la surface de la Terre.
Mais si la gravité de la Terre est suffisamment
grande pour faire tourner la Lune, pourquoi
n’agirait-elle pas sur les astronautes ? Pourquoi
les astronautes ne sentiraient-ils pas leurs
poids ? Pourquoi seraient-ils en apesanteur
? Pourquoi la gravité n’agirait-elle pas
sur eux ?
Comme vous l’avez deviné, si la gravité
de la Terre agit sur la Lune, elle agit clairement
sur les astronautes aussi.
Donc les astronautes subissent la gravité.
Ils ont un poids.
Ils ont une pesanteur.
Ils ne sont donc pas en apesanteur.
Au mieux, ils n’ont qu’un sentiment d’apesanteur.
Mais pourquoi ? Comment se fait-il qu’ils
puissent subir la gravité sans la sentir
? Et bien, ça, c’est une question très
profonde et très fondamentale qui conduira
Albert Einstein à la pensée la plus heureuse
de sa vie.
Off.
Mais avant de parler d’Einstein, il faut
que je vous donne l’explication Newtonienne
de ce sentiment d’apesanteur, qui est celle
donnée par Bruce sur e-penser.
D’après la loi de la chute des corps de
Galilée, l’astronaute et la station spatiale
tombent tout deux aussi vite.
Du coup, pour l’astronaute, la station spatiale
ne bouge pas.
Or, il ne voit que la station spatiale.
Il a donc l’impression de flotter par rapport
à tout ce qui l’entoure.
Donc, pour Newton, l’astronaute n’est
pas en apesanteur.
Il a un poids.
Mais son environnement immédiat l’induit
en erreur, et lui fait croire que la gravité
n’agit pas sur lui.
Alors.
Oui.
Ça marche comme explication.
Mais c’est pas super élégant.
Et puis, ça soulève une autre question fondamentale.
Pourquoi l’astronaute tomberait-il aussi
vite que la station spatiale ? Et bien, selon
Newton, il s’agit d’une conséquence de
l’intrigante égalité de la masse gravitationnelle
et de la masse inertielle.
Off.
La masse gravitationnelle est celle qui intervient
dans la loi de la gravitation de Newton, qui
dit que les objets avec une plus grande masse
gravitationnelle possède une plus grande
force d’attraction gravitationnelle.
La masse inertielle, quant à elle, c’est
celle qui intervient dans le principe fondamental
de la dynamique, qui dit qu’il faut plus
de force pour modifier le mouvement des objets
avec une plus grande masse inertielle.
Ces deux masses sont des concepts très différents.
Pourtant, Newton affirma qu’elles se devaient
d’être égales.
Mais pourquoi ? Pourquoi, se demanda Einstein
? Pourquoi la gravité des corps serait-elle
dictée par leur inertie ?
Off.
Selon la légende, Einstein se baladait un
jour dans les rues de Bern quand il vit un
homme tomber du haut d’une tour.
Einstein se précipita sur l’homme qui hurlait
de douleur et lui demanda : “Monsieur, monsieur,
monsieur, vous avez senti la gravité en tombant
?”
Alors, cette histoire est sans doute fausse.
Néanmoins, Einstein fut tout à coup convaincu
qu’un homme en chute libre ne pouvait pas
sentir la gravité, qu’il ne pouvait pas
sentir son poids, tout comme l’astronaute
là-haut.
Et il trouva une nouvelle explication absolument
révolutionnaire à cela L’homme en chute
libre et l’astronaute ne sentent pas leur
poids, non pas car ils sont induits en erreur
par leur environnement immédiat.
Ils sont sans poids, car ils n’ont pas de
poids.
Car le poids n’existe purement et simplement
pas.
Car la gravité n’est pas une attraction.
La gravité n’est pas une force.
La gravité n’est pas une force…
Et ça, en ses propres termes, ce fut la pensée
la plus heureuse d’Einstein.
Mais, la gravité n’est pas une force, qu’est-ce
que ça veut dire ? Que voulait vraiment dire
Einstein ? Pour répondre à ces questions,
il faut vivre et respirer la physique.
Comme le faisait Einstein.
Que sentez-vous en ce moment ? Quelles sont
les forces physiques que vous agir sur vous
?
Si j’y réfléchis vraiment…
Tout ce que je ressens, c’est quelque chose
au niveau de mes pieds.
Quelque chose qui pousse mes pieds.
Qui semble me pousser vers le haut.
Et bien cette force, Einstein s’exclama,
nous fait donc accélérer vers le haut.
Et c’est cette accélération vers le haut
que l’on appelle la gravité.
Autrement dit, ce que l’on appelle habituellement
la gravité vers le bas peut aussi s’appeler
accélération vers le haut !
Comme l’accélération dans un ascenceur.
Quand l’ascenseur accélère vers le bas,
mon poids dans l’ascenseur est plus faible.
Alors, selon Newton, cette mesure est plus
faible parce que je la mesure mal.
Mais Einstein n’est pas d’accord.
Selon Einstein, mon poids dans un ascenseur
qui accélère vers le bas est fondamentalement
plus faible, car la gravité dans l’ascenseur
est plus faible !
Off.
Si ça c’est pas étrange ! La gravité
dans l’ascenseur est déterminée par l’accélération
de l’ascenseur.
En fait, quand l’ascenseur est en chute
libre, c’est-à-dire quand il accélère
à 10 mètres par seconde carrée par rapport
au sol, la gravité dans l’ascenseur disparaît
purement et simplement.
Dans ce cas, mon poids mesuré dans l’ascenseur
serait nul.
Je n’aurais pas de poids.
Je serais en apesanteur.
Off.
Plus généralement, la pensée la plus heureuse
d’Einstein était de comprendre que la gravité
et l’accélération ne sont que les faces
opposées d’une même pièce.
C’est ce qu’Einstein appela le principe
d’équivalence, et c’est l’une des plus
heureuses pensées que quiconque ait jamais
eu.
C’est d’un génie éclatant !
Off.
Ainsi, en utilisant son principe d’équivalence,
Einstein apporta un éclairage nouveau à
la mystérieuse loi de la chute des corps
de Galilée.
Vous vous souvenez ? Galilée avait prouvé
qu’il était inconsistent de penser que
les objets plus lourds tombent plus vite.
Nul doute.
C’était brillant.
Vraiment brillant.
Mais de là à conclure que tous les objets
tombent aussi vite, il y avait encore un grand
pas à faire.
L’argument de Galilée n’était ni conclusif,
ni instructif.
Off.
Einstein rétorqua alors que si l’on a du
mal à comprendre la chute des objets, c’est
parce qu’on l’étudie constamment dans
le référentiel du sol.
Mais le sol, dit-il, n’est pas un référentiel
“naturel”.
En termes techniques, ce n’est pas un référentiel
galiléen.
Le sol accélère constamment vers le haut,
poussé par la pression des couches inférieures.
Off.
Il est en fait beaucoup plus naturel, dit
Einstein, d’étudier la chute des objets
depuis le référentiel des objets en chute,
car, dans le vide, ces objets ne sont sous
l’action d’aucune force.
Même pas la gravité.
Car la gravité n’est pas une force ! Et
donc, leur référentiel est galiléen.
Et dans ce référentiel, ces objets qui ne
subissent aucune force sont immobiles, et
c’est le sol qui accélère vers le haut.
Dans ce point de vue, la loi de la chute des
corps de Galilée devient tout à coup une
évidence.
Les objets atteignent donc le sol en même
temps car aucun de ces objets ne bouge dans
leur référentiel inertiel, et c’est le
sol qui accélère et les atteindra tous en
même temps !
Quel raisonnement fantastique ! Et au bout
du compte, bien plus que toutes les observations
expérimentales que je ne peux pas répéter
moi-même, c’est cette explication incroyablement
lumineuse de la mystérieuse loi de la chute
des corps de Galilée qui me donne envie de
croire en la théorie de la relativité générale
d’Einstein.
Allez Einstein ! Allez !
Off.
C’est en 1907 qu’Einstein eut cette pensée
la plus heureuse de sa vie.
C’était une pensée incroyable, une pensée
formidable.
Mais ce n’était qu’une pensée.
Pour transformer cette pensée en une théorie
crédible de la physique, Einstein savait
qu’il allait devoir réécrire complètement
la théorie de la mécanique de Newton.
C’était incroyablement ambitieux.
D’autant qu’Einstein n’était alors
qu’un inconnu, qui, la même année, se
vit refusé de nombreux positions de professeur.
D’ailleurs, le grand Max Planck conseilla
Einstein de renoncer à la quête d’une
théorie de la gravité.
La gravité semblait bien trop compliquée
pour lui.
Et aussi brillante que fusse la pensée d’Einstein,
ce n’était qu’un point de départ.
Pour aller plus loin, Einstein allait devoir
maîtriser le calcul tensoriel et la géométrie
des espaces courbes.
Il allait devoir être plus créatif que tous
les savants avant lui, il allait devoir être
plus malin que tous les génies de son temps.
En bref, il allait devoir devenir le plus
grand scientifique
de tous les temps.
Einstein allait-il être
à
la hauteur
de ses ambitions ?